[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous donc je me présentais
relais jaxxon aucun lien donc je suis
venu ce soir pour remplacer cédric
villani qui n'a pas pu faire le
déplacement
on va là en fait je suis là ce soir pour
vous parler un peu de ma vie qui est
comme mon nom de famille on va dire
original
je vais pas dire une vie plus enviable
parce que tout d'abord je ne pense pas
pas tous les jours du moins et puis
parce que je vais vous laisser en juger
par vous même
donc en fait si je suis ici ce soir
c'est pour vous parler d'une chose c'est
de ma maladie la mucoviscidose
je suis malade depuis toujours j'ai été
diagnostiquée à l'âge de 4 ans 1987
après de longues errances médicale et à
l'époque les médecins ne donnait pas
cher de ma peau et ne me donnait pas
beaucoup de chances de survie à court
terme
à partir de là où commencer pour moi les
vrais ennuis notamment les séjours en
institut à palavas les flots
ça peut faire rêver dit comme ça
seulement voilà là bas je subissais de
nombreuses cures antibiotiques
intraveineuse à forte dose et là ça fait
un petit peu moins élevé heureusement
les enfants cette force de pouvoir
s'adapter et finalement j'ai réussi
là-bas même dans certains endroits
sordides à m'amuser comme tous les
enfants comme tous les garçons et les
filles de mon âge sur cette diapositive
on peut voir quelques infirmières en
train de fumer leur cigarette dans un
service consacré à la mucoviscidose qui
touche principalement les poumons c'est
des années 80 quoi c'est un petit peu
particulier
vous remarquerez il ya quand même la
fenêtre est ouverte c'était quand même
pas des monstres
voilà donc ce va-et-vient il va durer
jusque jusqu'à mes 9 ans à peu près le
jour où les médecins annoncent à mes
parents en ma présence qu'il ne reste
que quelques années à vivre
4 tout au plus et qu'il va falloir
commencer à se faire à l'idée que donc
c'est là que vous comprenez à quel point
le corps médical peut parfois faire
preuve de finesse
heureusement mes parents non résigné et
même réseau du décide alors de me
retirer de la lino mène sur paris voir
une sommité
le grand spécialiste de la mucoviscidose
le professeur gérard lenoir à qui je
rends hommage aujourd'hui qui est
malheureusement décédé avec cet homme on
va commencer à aborder le sujet qui nous
réunit ce soir puisque c'était que
vraiment quelqu'un qui était dans la
conquête du territoire
ce véritable génie osé ils osaient
prendre des risques allez sur des
terrains compliqué même face à des cas
désespérés comme le mien chose
impossible de nos jours où la plupart
des essais thérapeutiques sont
malheureusement réservé aux gens n'ayant
pas trop subi les dégâts de la maladie
et dont je suis systématiquement exclus
seconde ce grand personnage donc va me
prendre en main et va me faire entrer
dans un protocole novateur de toute
façon totalement officieuse et va me
sortir de l'impasse fatale dans laquelle
je me trouvais
grâce à lui j'ai non seulement été
sauvés mais j'ai connu de mes 10 à quasi
20 ans véritable repos vis-à-vis de la
maladie
j'ai pu pratiquer du sport de façon
intensive et j'ai pu aussi et j'ai pu
aussi suivre une scolarité normale et ce
jusqu'à mon baccalauréat scientifique a
précisé
seulement voilà la puberté venant et
c'est une période difficile comme
certains ça ici et de plus je ne suis
pas très bien les traitements forcément
et la maladie ne fait pas très bon
ménage non plus avec les changements
hormonaux
j'ai donc vu ressurgir les vieux démons
les choses se sont vraiment aggravée le
jour où j'ai contracté un germe terrible
le pseudomonas aeruginosa plus connu
dans mon milieu sous le nom de
pyocyanique c'est la bête noire des gens
qui partagent mon parcours
nous sommes en 2003 au moins de 5 ans
microbes va littéralement ronger mais
pour je vais pas séduit je vais perdre
environ 20 % de capacité respiratoire
sachant déjà que je ne resterai pas à
pleins poumons c'est peu de dire je vais
voir ma capacité pulmonaire chuté à 20
30 % ce qui est très peu d'erreurs
de nombreuses cures antibiotiques succès
successives se montre complètement
inutile les médecins sont désemparés je
crache chaque jour l'équivalent d'un
gobelet de glaire c'est le bon mot un
peu embêtant du speech parce qu'après il
ya de la cocktail ou quoi faire monter
des économies donc certaines de ses
glaires sont ensanglantées
ce qui prouve que chaque jour mais mes
poumons sont détériorées de plus en plus
c'est un peu l'impasse y a plus grand
chose à faire mais seulement voilà donc
vous inquiétez pas c'est un petit peu
plus positif quand même par la suite je
suis noctambules de nature et au cours
d'une de mes nombreuses 1 samedi j'ai pu
visionner sur une chaîne du service
public
un reportage intitulé la guerre
d'eiffage dans ce reportage on en suit
un américain atteindre une plaie au
genou est ouverte depuis plusieurs
années est colonisée par un
staphylocoque doré un germe tout aussi
sympathique que le mien le sujet du
documentaire son voyage en géorgie
atteint d'une de cette infection ostéo
articulaires c'est la seule option qui
lui est donné c'est l'amputation
seulement voilà ça c'est sans compter
sur nos amis géorgien et leurs fameux
bactériophages alors c'est
bactériophages se sont tout petits virus
qui mesure entre 25 et 200 nanomètres et
qui se nourrissent de bactéries en fait
ils ont été complètement oubliés en
occident et sont encore utilisés là bas
et sont connus sous le nom
d'antibiotiques de staline ça fait un
peu peur dit comme ça il n'empêche que
ce monsieur donc après plusieurs
traitements et trois semaines de soins
repart chez lui à l'autre bout du monde
sans ses béquilles s'appelait refermer
son affection ra dickey stupéfaction
j'en parle donc un bon médecin et à mon
frère qui est également docteur tout le
monde ne rien peu sonné si ça marchait
ça fait bien longtemps qu'on sait rien
et chez nous dans nos hôpitaux
donc personne n'y croit vraiment sauf
que en faisant un peu des recherches
encore je m'aperçois non seulement ce
n'est pas du charlatanisme
mais qu'en plus les bactériophages ont
une réelle efficience et qu'il n'y a
aucune raison qu'ils ne fonctionnent pas
sur mon infection
c'est donc seul épaulé par nos nerfs que
je décide de prendre contact avec
l'institut sur place à tbilissi en
géorgie avec qui j'ai tout de suite de
très bons échanges
nous sommes en 2008 la guerre entre la
russie et la géorgie éclate
il va falloir que j'attende si je vais
entreprendre un voyage au final ça tu
attends tu aurais été bénéfique puisque
mon frère fini par se décider à
m'accompagner et c'est donc tous les
deux que nous partons là bas en février
2009 des pardons pour la géorgie qui
sort juste de guerre la maladie mais y
en beaucoup enfermé
je ne suis pas beaucoup je n'ai pas
beaucoup voyagé pour le coup le
dépaysement est total
le post soviétisme à quelque chose de
très particulier déboussolant il vous
allez des chiens errants en meute
vous avez une circulation anarchique
avec des vieilles trabant des enfants
des rues c'est un autre monde
je me rends donc un institut elia va qui
fabrique eiffage et je fais et je
rencontre une fille a quitté l'as
excellente exercices de prononciation
mais c'est aussi la microbiologiste en
chef de l'institut et ce avec elle que
je suis en contact depuis maintenant
plus d'un an
je suis le premier français la première
personne atteinte de mucoviscidose et
mis à part quelques américains dans
celui dont je vous ai parlé plus tôt le
premier occidental à me rendre sur place
pas très rassurant d'autant plus que la
prise en charge est vraiment minime
je dois me rendre une fois tous les
trois jours dans une clinique vérifier
que tout se passe bien
à part ça je repars avec des
bactériophages sous le bras dans mon
hôtel ou bien content pour le coup que
mon frère soit là je commence donc mais
aérosol apparemment très content d'être
assez souriant sauf que au bout de
quelques minutes souffle coupé
les bactériophages dans la nature ce
sont les prédateurs naturels des
bactéries il y en a partout sur vos
vêtements sur votre pauvre dans l'eau
dans les eaux usées même si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire et en fait leur mode
d'action est assez simple il s'arrime à
la bactérie les injecte leur matériel
génétique ils se servent de la
machinerie cellulaire du germe pour se
reproduire
jusqu'à ce que celui ci explose une fois
leurs hôtes mort il se répand
d'avant-tour colonies de bactéries et
ainsi de suite face à l'infection
pulmonaire qu'il ya dans les poumons les
petites bêtes sont au festin sauf que
bon cette liste bactérienne c'est à dire
un gros nombre de bactéries mortes dans
les poumons on va surexcités mon système
immunitaire et ventre est née une énorme
réaction inflammatoire
au bout d'une semaine mon état est le
même on to d'oxygène est en chute libre
et je n'arrive pas à dégager les
bronches
le problème c'est que mon frère qui
reste une semaine avec moi doit rentrer
en france et que je me retrouve seule en
géorgie sous la surveillance éloigné de
quelques médecins géorgien qui
baragouine en anglais aussi élaboré que
le mien autant vous dire que c'est un
peu la panique
sauf que voilà j'ai serré les dents et
au bout de dix jours miracle ou mentaux
d'oxygène remonte en flèche
je commence avec pouvoir cracher dégager
les bronches et je constate que je trash
dix fois moins qu'avant je rentre donc
en france est on arrivé à ma mère
constate directement changement le pari
était le bon depuis ce séjour on état
est stabilisé la maladie est toujours là
avec les problèmes qu'elles s'entraident
mais j'essaie de faire comme vous et de
mener une vie la plus normale possible
j'ai depuis pu travailler par exemple
comme pigiste vaucluse matin c'est pas
très loin d'ici
pendant plus de quatre ans j'ai
également
j'ai découvert là-bas d'ailleurs les
rouages politiques associatives de notre
bonne vieille cité j'ai également monté
une association fage espoirs qui est
requis même si elle ne fonctionne plus
aujourd'hui qu'à me comme elle le
fonctionner avant eux m'a permis devrait
à la reconnaissance des bakir fages dans
nos pays j'ai également participé à de
nombreux reportages sur le sujet est
aussi à des conférences donc c'était
cette expérience m'a vraiment ouvert au
monde
en géorgie les choses ont aussi beaucoup
changé de nom les médias ayant
énormément relayé l'existence des
bactériophages aujourd'hui
de nombreuses personnes de nos pays
occidentaux sont désireuses de se rendre
sur place pour bénéficier de traitement
ce qui a fait exploser les tarifs de
plus des gens avides d'argent bien sûr
se sont emparés de la chose et on monte
des agences de voyages fage tourisme qui
propose des séjours pour des sommes très
importantes si je voulais aujourd'hui
bénéficier de ce traitement
je n'en n'aurai pas les moyens
financiers heureusement j'ai encore des
contacts sur place et j'arrive encore à
me faire livrer des bactériophages de
façon pas très légal chez moi
directement à domicile
je tenais ce soir à rendre hommage à des
gens comme géré en gabarre quelqu'un de
très courageux
c'est le directeur général de faire ici
dans ce format le seul laboratoire
français à produire d'eiffage en france
et qui fait un travail de fou et qui est
sur le point de réussir son pari puisque
aujourd'hui il ya des nombreux essais
thérapeutiques en france à partir de
fages et qui viennent de faire ici des
pharmas et ce monsieur fait un travail
formidable
je voudrais aussi remercier fabrice
sabres fabrice barrès ce que je sais moi
je avec son pseudo sait jamais de quoi
demain avoir invité ce soir a parlé donc
c'était mon histoire de conquête de
territoires merci de l'avoir écoutée au
revoir
[Applaudissements]